-I'm excited to see you.
It's interesting.
In your intro there,
it kind of changed from earlier,
but I introduced you
as America's sweetheart.
Is that --
-Well, I just did a movie
with Reese Witherspoon,
Anna Kendrick, and Ashton Kutcher.
-Wow.
[ Cheers ]
-And I think
we all saw it coming.
But --
[ Laughter ]
At one point,
somebody referred to Reese
as America's sweetheart,
and she didn't take
that title on, and I just --
I told her,
"Well, I guess I'll take it."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-We always love when you come
to visit us,
and you brought us something
interesting to me.
This is --
You've been on the road.
You're doing your tour,
"Hello Again."
I just want to give it
a little quick plug.
Pittsburgh, Cleveland, Detroit,
Columbus, Ithaca, Boston,
Washington, Philly, Portland,
San Francisco, New Orleans...
-New Orleans, Chicago, Madison.
-Chicago, Madison, Wisconsin.
New York, New York.
-New York City, yeah.
-This is a big tour.
That's a big tour.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There's even more.
I think there's 40 dates.
Those are just --
-Wow!
Some dates right there.
-Yeah, those are some.
-But you've been travelling
a lot,
and you've had some experiences.
Let's just say that.
-Yeah.
-At the airport.
And you've taken photos,
and you've brought the photos
to our show.
-Yes.
-And can I show the photo first
or do you want to talk about
the situation?
-Well, I'll tell you, you know,
we are in the middle
of a pandemic.
And I was in between cities,
and I was hungry.
And so, I scoured the airport
for a place to sit alone,
away from everyone
to be as safe as I could
to take my mask off and eat.
-Yeah.
-And I laid out all of my food
on the seat next to me.
And right as I started eating --
and I'm telling you,
the area was empty.
Show the picture.
[ Laughter ]
These are all empty seats.
So are these.
[ Laughter ]
So are across from her.
-But right behind --
-So was the whole row
that she was sitting in.
But she sat right there,
right behind me.
-This other photo is something
that we can all help you with.
You brought us --
You brought us a problem
that we can give you a solution.
-I'm hoping.
Here's the thing is, I don't
follow a lot of pop culture,
and I'll be fair, you know,
and honest and say,
I'm not great at recognizing
a lot of celebrities...
-Yes.
-...because I don't follow
a lot of pop culture.
-But you're America's
sweetheart.
-I am America's sweetheart.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
-People follow what I'm doing.
-People follow --
Oh, I understand.
-Yeah.
-Of course.
Of course.
That's what they do, yeah.
[ Applause ]
-Another standing ovation.
So, I was sitting
on this flight,
and everybody that walked on
kept saying to the woman
next to me, "Oh, my gosh.
I'd know that face from anywhere
or even with a mask on.
Look at you.
I know that hair."
And I was like,
"Who the hell is this?"
[ Laughter ]
And, of course,
she had a mask on,
and so I snuck a picture
and sent it to my wife,
and I was like, "Who is this?"
And then, she didn't know.
And then we sent it
to everyone else that was
celebrity-obsessed.
Nobody knows who this person is.
-And you didn't
want to ask the person.
You're not --
-Well, no, halfway through
the flight,
there was a spider on her leg,
and, uh...
[ Laughter ]
And I said, "Oh, excuse me.
You have a spider on your leg."
And she said, "Oh, my gosh.
Thank you."
And she brushed it off.
And I was like,
"I don't know that voice."
[ Laughter ]
"Who is this person?"
-All right.
So you brought the photo.
-Yeah.
-And this is the person
that was sitting next to you.
And do we know who this?
-Who is that?
Please, call 1-800...
[ Laughter ]
-Let me see this here.
-And whoever she is,
please don't be upset with me.
-She has red hair.
-And a widow's peak.
-Is it Debra Messing?
-No.
I feel like Deborah and I
would --
[ Laughter ]
Let me look at this.
-Yeah.
I have no clue.
Jenna Fischer?
-It's America's sweetheart.
-What?
No, no, no, it's not.
-No, no.
-No, it's not Jenna Fischer.
-She's very pretty.
Very pretty.
She looks like she's married.
That's a wedding ring.
-Yeah.
-So she's married.
-She carries a yellow bag.
-A yellow bag.
[ Laughter ]
This last one is --
I don't even know
if you want to even set this up.
I'm just gonna show the picture.
-Well, I do want to say,
this person wasn't --
-It's a tough situation.
-It wasn't that she was mean.
She just wasn't
terribly friendly when we
sat next to each other.
And I thought,
"Well, I'm not gonna be
mean back, but this is..."
-Okay. Here's the photo.
Here's the photo.
We blurred her face out.
This actually happened to you.
[ Laughter ]
What in the world?
-Well, you know what?
-What in the world happens
in your life
where this happens in your life?
-I was sitting there.
And this was obviously
pre-pandemic.
And we had our masks off, and
I started to see this happen,
and I was like,
"Oh, boy. Uh-oh."
[ Laughter ]
"Somebody's sleepy."
And then, she went down.
And she was rest--
She was snuggled
into my shoulder.
[ Laughter ]
-You didn't say anything?
You didn't wake her up?
-No. I let her sleep
the whole flight.
-Wow.
I want to, once again,
talk about -- you're on tour
starting January 11th.
-Yeah, "Hello Again"
is the name of the tour.
And it sounds obvious,
because there is
the obvious reason
of, "Hello, again.
I haven't toured
in a couple of years."
But there's another reason
that it's called "Hello Again."
I'm not gonna tell you why.
-Yeah, I know.
That's what
makes you very interesting.
You told me that to find out
why it's called "Hello Again"
that I have to see the tour
and find out.
-The whole tour.
You have to buy tickets.
-No, no, no, no.
But at the end of your act,
you understand why it's called
"Hello Again."
-Yes, and it's a very fun moment
that you don't want to miss.
[ Laughter ]
-Tig Notaro, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
For more information
on her "Hello Again" tour,
go to tignotaro.com.
-America's sweetheart.